Oh,
I don't know,
I can't answer a question like that.
You know,
you say you're optimistic and,
and,
uh,
you know,
the world is full of surprises.
God Lord knows,
I mean,
in 2001,
we thought we had no enemies world.
We were on a course.
The only problem seemed to be that the
stock market was a stock market.
Boom.
Seemed to be a little bit over.
And look what happened.
The history of the course,
the course of the world or the course of
this country at least change which
affected the course of the world.
And I don't think you can be too
sanguine about what the future holds.
Um,
well,
I think this age will be remembered as a
time in which America really struggled
with.
It's a world leadership.
Uh,
the United States,
uh,
went into a new phase of,
of,
uh,
of economic development as it's,
as it's,
as it's technologies became more
dominant.
Population changed from,
became an older population,
began to become an increasingly Latino
population.
Um,
I,
I don't have a,
a,
a quick adjective,
the age of,
of what,
uh,
whatever.
Uh,
but I think those are the dominant.
Nah.